I were here the Women's International
Master Irina zhenya Irina you've been to
this tournament many times before in st.
Louis what are your goals here for this
event so it's a strong field this year
and my goal would be just to break top
five it seems like many as women here
have very very advanced degrees and
you're no exception you're getting our
PhD at Carnegie Mellon how hard is it to
balance school especially a doctorate
program with your chest study so I very
little time left for chest but the
weekends are still dedicated to the
chest what do you know about the two new
women they're here Alina Katz and
Victoria Navy play them before I have
not played them before but I know a lot
of cats because I used to go to chest
cool her father owns when I just arrived
here so I here to her many good things
and I know how talented young
prospective she is and this is the White
Knight School in Brighton Beach yeah
that's right you got it right
it's a excellent chess school I started
out when I came here at fifteen that's
my first just destination was that
chesticles does it take any kind of
ruthlessness to get to the top here of
chess and the world championship match
taking place concurrently practically
who do you have is the favorite and by
how much that would be a vision of
reigning world champion Boris Gelfand
sure you already knew that
thanks for refresher
I was root for a man
another most important question you were
upstairs all the women were getting
their makeovers how did you decide upon
a hairstyle what was your moment of
inspiration um it really nothing my
decisions I said higher style is that I
got he was pretty good and talented and
he made a decision for me so so chess
players can give up control in certain
areas definitely sounds good
well it looks lovely we wish you well
trying to win your first US Women's
Championship thank you so much address
thank you